[Music]
on this thursday night historic heat
2021 was the sixth hottest year on
record another warning drastic action is
needed to tackle climate change we
really do need to reduce carbon
emissions plus building resiliency our
first nation is adapting to withstand
climate change
kids and covet vaccinations why isn't it
happening faster the mixed messages and
misinformation
cast out by his mother
the queen strips prince andrew of his
royal and military titles and
spectacular donation i
had this idea one man solves two
problems with 27 000 kilograms of
potatoes
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the latest data on
global warming which makes it crystal
clear temperatures are going up and
going up quickly new data from nasa
shows the average global surface
temperature in 2021 made it the sixth
warmest year on record temperatures in
north america were on average 1.4
degrees above average and extreme
weather events leading to costly and
deadly disasters are happening more
often in 2021 parts of canada had
record-setting heat waves raging
wildfires severe drought powerful
tornadoes and heavy flooding
the damage from record flooding in
british columbia is estimated to have
cost 7.5 billion dollars scientists say
extreme weather events driven by climate
change will continue to accelerate
unless bold action is taken
jackson proskow reports
the warning signs are here and there are
more of them than ever
earth is warming the climate changing
rapidly what you see is enormous
increases um in the in the rate at which
you would see uh an extreme event so so
something that that before was a one in
a hundred year event well now it's a one
in ten year event though 2021 didn't set
a record for temperatures it came close
part of a pattern that has spawned more
extreme weather events with greater
frequency
in 2021 the canadian prairies baked as
severe drought set in
bc burned
then flooded texas froze
hurricanes delivered unprecedented rain
and destruction rare december tornadoes
walloped the american heartland all of
these things are now being more and more
strongly tied to the fact that we have
warmed the planet uh by more than a
degree celsius over the last uh hundred
or years two things are certain humans
are to blame and they're bound to suffer
through more extreme events there's no
going back that means planning and
building for a future very much like our
present adaptation is also on the table
we really do need to reduce carbon
emissions but we also desperately need
to
come up with policies that will allow
people to adapt to these changes as much
as possible though global carbon
emissions soared in 2021 experts believe
the worst impacts of climate change can
still be avoided they're also realistic
about the challenges that lie ahead
right now i think the the goal has to be
to let's just temper the harshest part
but that's going to require some resolve
and some
agreement there is still optimism that
international agreements like cop 26
will eventually put the planet on a
better track one where temperatures
remain higher but stop climbing right
now we are in control and what we do
as a society and obviously globally
makes a big difference to what's going
to happen in the future
a future where we live with the
realities of today and the consequences
of the past
jackson costco global news washington
and 2022 has started with some extreme
weather parts of south america are in
the middle of a sweltering heat wave
right now this week argentina's capital
recorded its second highest temperature
ever 41.1 degrees celsius power grids
failed leaving hundreds of thousands of
people without electricity and today
australia matched its hottest day on
record hitting 50.7 degrees celsius it's
expected to get even hotter tomorrow
here in canada litton british columbia
holds the record for highest temperature
ever recorded in this country it reached
a sweltering 49.6 degrees celsius last
summer just days before a wildfire tore
through the village destroying most of
the homes the fire also displaced
residents living in nearby kanaka bar
it's an indigenous community about 15
kilometers south of lytton and it is now
preparing to rebuild as heather yurix
west explains the community has
partnered with a team of researchers to
design and build homes more resilient to
extreme weather
so this is my kitchen area for 25 years
chief patrick michelle's family filled
their kaneka bar home with memories
until one day last june under a
scorching summer sun it was gone we're
all able to leave with nothing but the
shirts on your backs
oh my god look at that the fire jumped
from home to home to home willy-nilly
one of my friends described it as a
dragon days after shattering canada's
heat record hitting a high of 49.6
degrees both litton and kaneka bar were
on fire entire communities of homes and
businesses didn't stand a chance the
homes in kanaka bar
burned down in about 20 minutes
part of the problem wasn't so much the
fire as it was the thermal
transmissivity of the heat weeks after
the fire researchers at calgary's
southern alberta institute of technology
reached out with an offer to help to not
only rebuild the community but to do it
in a way that would withstand future
fires storms and floods we don't want
things that will just withstand fire for
10 minutes we need things that withstand
fire for a much longer period of time
i'm an indigenous person i build
buildings and infrastructure for the
next hundred years for my great great
grandchildren's use and benefit and so
when the first homes are rebuilt this
spring they will be built to last the
community is funding a study that will
see researchers from state okanagan
college foresight canada and seagull
construction working together to design
and build between four and eight test
homes able to withstand whatever climate
events come next people will be moving
into them but we'll be following
everyone who's living in them for a year
after they
occupy the homes and most importantly we
know there will be more climate events
in the region
how those homes stand up to those
climate events chief michelle says
everything learned from the research in
kanaka bar will be made available to any
community looking to adapt for extreme
weather so the next time that fiery
dragon comes to town those living there
can be a little more prepared heather
urex west global news calgary
now to the pandemic quebec premier says
hospitalizations in his province have
not peaked yet but cases have and the
province is ready to ease some
restrictions as of monday the
province-wide 10 pm curfew will be
lifted students are also set to return
to in-class learning on monday
new brunswick is imposing a new 16-day
lockdown to help curb soaring case
counts there and hospitalizations new
brunswick's top doctor says it is a
matter of life and death the province
will move to level three measures on
saturday morning the most restrictive
social gatherings will be limited to
single household bubbles gyms and
entertainment venues will be shut down
and there will be no indoor public
gatherings at home learning is also
being extended to january 31st
both newfoundland and labrador and pei
are delaying the return to in-person
learning until at least january 24th
because of a spike in cases pei's
premier says it could be two weeks
before the omicron wave begins to
subside
when we open we want to do everything we
can to stay open
because we know the starts and stops are
even more challenging and troubling for
students teachers families and staff
the provinces and territories are
working to vaccinate all eligible
children now but the rates appear to be
slowing for kids aged 5 to 11. just over
45 percent of children in that age group
have received their first dose just two
percent of five to 11 year olds have
both shots
jamie morocco reports some parents still
have questions about the vaccine
i think at some point we're just going
to end up getting covet but i i feel
better that we at least are we have some
protection against it morale durham is
taking her kids to get their second
covet shots but she's in the minority i
find this is a missed opportunity
because we have a really well evaluated
vaccine also for children parental
hesitancy is understandable everyone
wants only what's best for their kids
but is messaging partly to blame our
national advisory committee on
immunization says two doses may be
offered to children 5 to 11 not should
and families can face a barrage of
misinformation in chat groups and less
than credible sources there's no doubt
in my mind that the effects of the
illness itself both short term and long
term are much more detrimental to
children than the vaccine health canada
says no safety concerns were found in
clinical trials of pfizer's pediatric
shot and recent data from the u.s where
more than 8.6 million doses have been
administered to kids 5 to 11 reveals
side effects are exceedingly rare
calgary pediatric emergency physician
stephen friedman studied
hospitalizations in kids who do get
covet and stresses the importance of
vaccination what our study shows if
they're severe enough to be hospitalized
they have a risk of a severe adverse
outcome but shot or not experts admit
omicron is now changing the landscape i
think it's really important that we
strongly advocate for the vaccines for
those who are vulnerable to
landing in hospital that's been the
power of the vaccines and and that's
still holding true with omicron but i
also think that we have to be honest uh
about
that the vaccines are not in fact
stopping transmission if they did we
wouldn't be in this situation a
situation we have to adapt to but the
science is clear vaccination is still
the best option we have to protect
ourselves and our kids against covet 19.
jamie morocco global news toronto
after some confusion today about vaccine
rules for canadian cross-border truck
drivers the federal government now says
they will be required to be fully
vaccinated against cobit 19. on saturday
unvaccinated truckers will face
mandatory testing and isolation the
industry warns that will put more stress
on the already strained supply chain the
canadian trucking alliance says it
expects to lose 10 to 15 percent of its
cross-border commercial drivers when the
mandate takes effect sidelining 12 to
sixteen thousand truckers abigail beamon
reports on the changes and the expected
fallout
i don't agree with this whole vaccine
nonsense trucker lackey mcarthur doesn't
want the shot and a looming edict
barring unvaccinated cross-border work
won't change that there's plenty of
loads in canada i mean
i'll still be kept busy it just means
across border traffic well you're not
worried about losing your job no
come saturday new rules mean
unvaccinated truckers entering canada
will be subject to testing and
quarantine
wednesday night the cbsa said canadian
truckers would be exempt late thursday
the health transport and public safety
minister said that information was
shared in error and there are no
exemptions for canadians confusion aside
the issue remains since the united
states has a similar policy which comes
into force a week later so really what
has to happen
for relief in the supply chain
is both ottawa and washington
need to move simultaneously everything
that you get comes by a truck so if we
have less drivers and less trucks on the
road
your stores aren't going to fill up as
fast existing driver shortages mean
there are already supply chain issues
removing thousands more from the
workforce will add pressure increasing
the rate per mile some companies have
been offering higher pay for
cross-border routes or incentives to get
vaccinated over the last few weeks we've
really worked really hard with our guys
to get them in help them get booked for
vaccines get them to where they need to
be to get a vaccination the vast
majority of truckers are vaccinated but
the true impact on the supply chain and
consumer prices won't be clear for a
while
abigail beeman global news ottawa
opposition mps in ottawa are calling on
the federal government to suspend its
analysis of canadians cell phone
location data last month the public
health agency of canada acknowledged it
has been purchasing access to the
information to analyze the movement of
canadians mike li couture reports on the
questions about how that data is
collected and if canadians knew about it
if you've got a cell phone your mobile
carrier is collecting information about
your movements every day
that data is often sold and it turns out
the public health agency of canada has
been one of the buyers during the
pandemic a ping on a map just because
you or i went to costco how does that
impact or how does that affect public
health policy that question will be put
to canada's top doctor teresa tam and
health minister zhaniv zuklow when they
appear before the parliamentary
committee looking into this for now the
public health agency of canada says that
data will be used to analyze the
movement of populations in canada to
help inform public health policy during
this pandemic the information gathered
was de-identified meaning no data could
be linked to individual canadians
movements but privacy experts say it's
not bulletproof you have to use strong
de-identification protocols combined
with the risk of re-identification
framework that reduces the likelihood of
re-identification but doesn't make it
impossible some believe this should
start a wider conversation about how
much of our information is bought and
sold without us even knowing we're in a
context in which um
there may be there are is a need for
additional
safeguards and oversight when it comes
to
de-identified data and we just don't
have that in the legislation a
conversation that's been renewed because
of public health but could help overhaul
privacy laws michael couture global news
ottawa
thrown out coming up what the queen has
done to prince andrew before he faces a
sex abuse lawsuit
a dramatic move by the queen today she
is distancing herself and the royal
family from her second son prince andrew
he has been stripped of his military
titles and all of his royal patronages
and will no longer be known as his royal
highness he'll face the sexual abuse
lawsuit against him in the u.s as a
private citizen it's clear the queen and
the military want to shield themselves
from any potential outcome crystal
commansing reports
prince andrew is no longer the colonel
of the famed grenadier guards all of his
military titles have been returned and
he will no longer be known as his royal
highness
a statement from buckingham palace
confirming the termination ends by
saying the duke of york will continue
not to undertake any public duties and
is defending this case as a private
citizen
that case is a civil lawsuit in the u.s
brought by virginia jeffrey who says
prince andrew sexually assaulted her
when she was 17. a claim he denies and
unsuccessfully tried to have thrown out
of court this is very definitely the
queen distancing herself in her platinum
jubilee year 70 years on the throne a
unique
achievement and someone who
has given devoted service unfortunately
the same cannot be said of all her
family royal commentator richard
fitzwilliams says andrew has simply
become toxic the reputational damage is
done
more than 100 veterans had urged the
queen to take action writing we are
particularly upset and angry that prince
andrew remains a member of the armed
forces and continues to hold military
titles positions and ranks including
that of vice admiral of the royal navy
in windsor brits are standing by the
queen i think the queen will rise above
it she's she's uh
you know she's been around for a very
long time and she's an extremely wise
and sensible lady
now this is not the first royal scandal
but it does hit close to home it's the
first time the queen has had to take
such action against one of her own sons
crystal gamson global news london
ahead a landmark war crimes verdict
against a former syrian officer
there is a landmark court verdict in a
war crimes case involving syrians who
suffered abuse or lost relatives at the
hands of bashar al-assad's regime a
german court sentenced a former syrian
colonel to life in prison for crimes
against humanity anwar raslan is linked
to the torture of at least 4 000 people
at a prison outside of damascus a decade
ago it is the first ever conviction on
charges of state-backed torture
committed during syria's civil war
it's a recognition of the crimes
committed in syria so i hope that this
sentence and this verdict will be
a strong pace for future work
raslan denied the allegations against
him he fled syria in 2012 and went to
germany where police began investigating
his background survivors of torture in
syria have had limited options for
justice western powers have tried to
refer cases to the international
criminal court but those attempts have
been blocked by russia and china it's
hoped this case will be a blueprint for
future prosecutions
spuds of kindness next to quebec man
chips in big to help prince edward
island
so this is henrietta an adventurous pet
chicken who flew the coop in dramatic
fashion last weekend henrietta lives in
the garage of a nova scotia plumbing
business and snuck onto a truck as a
stowaway not the first time she's done
that they say she likes to travel she
made it to a town about 10 minutes away
and was found wandering the streets and
was taken in by a wildlife shelter
henrietta has since made the trip back
home safe and sound
well we could all use some more
uplifting news these days so tonight we
leave you with a story about making the
best of a tough situation it involves
pei potatoes and one man's effort to
help solve two problems at once here's
mike armstrong
yeah they are a staple in fact potatoes
are about as basic a staple as they get
sam watts goes through a lot of them and
thankfully right now has a lot of them
watts runs the welcome hall mission in
montreal its food bank helps about 2 500
people a week add to that the hundreds
and hundreds it feeds every day in our
kitchens we're making about 7 000 meals
every week
that can use up a lot of potatoes now
the fact watts warehouse is fully
stocked with potatoes is thanks to a
donation by this man mack watson is a
retired geologist who wanted to help the
twist is it wasn't the mission that was
the inspiration in the middle of night
one about about three weeks ago
i
had this idea
watson had been following news of the
situation in pei after two cases of a
potato fungus were found in october
ottawa banned exports to the u.s pei
potato farmers had just had one of their
best years in memory and are now looking
at huge losses it's extremely tough
we've all lost a bit our ambition our
our love for what we do farmer robin
stein says he may have to destroy as
much as 70 percent of his crop
province-wide about 120 million dollars
worth of potatoes can't go to market it
was stein who sold the trailer load to
the montreal mission it was only a drop
in the bucket
but one he appreciates
it was a wonderful thing to be a part of
people outside the province are are
thinking about watson says there was a
message in what he did he wanted the
farmers to know the rest of the country
cares well pei wasn't the only place
that heard that message the mission says
it's already gotten calls from people
wanting to donate and other missions in
the country looking for help setting up
something similar
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is okanagan lake near
kelowna bc we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
and hope to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]